in the present day
2021 it's become more so of an ideology
and within that ideology you have the
extremes of identity politics where you
have hierarchy hierarchies that are
based on identity markers that for
example if you are white you can't have
a say on race um which i just think is
[ __ ] ridiculous we're all racialized
people and you know if we want to find a
way to bring unity we need to be able to
to
talk and we need to be able to have the
uncomfortable conversations but you know
there are these
hierarchies that you can't even question
um you have things like performative
activism where people think you know
just a
six slide infographic is going to change
the world well i'm sorry to tell you
that i i don't think that's how that's
how it works and you get to
dots people online if you don't agree
with them you get to shame people in the
comment sections or in twitter threads
um where binary thinking is encouraged
again that pro or anti-black or white
with us or against us there's just no
regard for nuance um
and also it
always looks like a competition to
outwork the other person to
say actually i don't want to be
i don't need my voice to be uplifted
just because of my skin color is what
i'm saying of value yes and exactly as
you're saying is my business actually a
good business and it just so happens
that i'm black right yes because it's
it's one of those things again where i
understand i can say that i understand
the intention behind it right looking at
the people that are most um
underrepresented
and uplifting those people but then when
does it become a little bit or a lot
infantilizing to me it just ends up
being again that performative activism
almost but i think they are things that
start very much well in tension but a
lot of people myself included
i i don't want you to do me any favors
because of the color of my skin i know
that i'm very good at what i do
and if i had let's say a brick and
mortar shop i want you to be there
because my products are actually good
and the service is actually good not
because of the color of my skin
that was africa brooke wow i am so
excited for this episode today and i
cannot wait for you to listen to her
insights her thoughts and our
conversation she's an incredibly
eloquent speaker she's vulnerable she's
honest and it's something i so
appreciate
i know i got something from it it was
very impactful for me and i hope that
you gain something meaningful from this
conversation too
africa is from zimbabwe and resides in
britain
she's a writer speaker and consultant
her work focuses on self-sabotage and
self-censorship which began when she got
sober five years ago after seven
relapses
in 2016 she became curious about human
behavior and the concept of
self-sabotage and after taking from her
own subjective experience she began to
look at these things through the lens of
the collective which led to her writing
a now viral open letter called why i'm
leaving the cult of wokeness which has
been read by almost five million people
i highly recommend you check out
africa's own two podcasts called
unfiltered with africa and beyond the
self and if after listening to this
episode you're interested in learning
and exploring more of africa's work she
has a signature workshop on how to stop
self-censoring in the age of cancer
culture which you can learn all the
details about in her website i'll link
below for you i wish she lived closer so
we could have more of these
conversations in person because i feel
like we could be such close friends so i
really hope you enjoyed this
conversation and without further ado
let's get into the episode okay we are
here welcome back everyone to the
podcast i am so excited for this episode
i'm honored to speak with someone that
i've grown really inspired by
for multiple reasons
africa brooke thank you for being here
uh ellen thank you so so much for
inviting me to have a conversation with
you um we've been trying to make this
happen for a little while and i always
believe that everything happens in its
time
and
i i i also don't know exactly what is
going to be coming up i think i say this
every time i sit with someone but it's
always true i have no idea where this is
going to go
but just from seeing the conversations
that you've had with other people
i just know that it's going to be a very
balanced nuanced approach um so i'm very
very thrilled thank you so much thank
you
yeah i resonate so much with the work
that you put out into the world and i
often find myself
listening to your long instagram videos
while i'm nursing my baby to sleep in
the dark with headphones on
and being in the realm of social media
myself where there's lots of room for
self-censoring and criticism
i just get really excited about this
topic so i think it's going to be a
really fun conversation
yes me too
so for those listening today i just want
to say that we're going to be talking
about some really
relevant topics in about culture about
our culture today and africa has an
amazing transformation story from her
evolution
and just where she is today how far
you've come and so
let's just begin
yes yes so i think the best way to
really paint the picture would just to
share some of my worldly titles what i
do in the world so
i am a consultant i'm an accredited
coach and i'm a writer as well and as a
coach and as a consultant i focus on two
main pillars so the first one is
self-sabotage and the second is
self-censorship
and self-sabotage in particular is
something that i've been closely looking
at and i'm very familiar with
but i've been looking at it in an
objective way for the past five years
and what led me to even discover what
the concept was
was my journey with sobriety very
specifically getting myself from being a
binge drinker a blackout drinker from
the age of 14
and then eventually getting sober in
2016 at the age of 24
and
my decision to
my decision to abstain from alcohol and
give my life myself the life that i
actually deserved to live it wasn't
a romantic process it wasn't
you know this beautiful decision that i
just made one day and i followed through
with what i said it was a very dark and
revealing process i had tried many times
to get sober seven times
consciously
but even in between that i had promised
that i would never drink as much i had
apologized for things that i couldn't
remember i had lost so many people in my
life
i had seen so many sides to myself that
i just
that created so much shame and blame and
guilt
um in the span of a decade in the most
formative years of my life if you will
from the age of 14 to 24
so that decision the final decision i
made in 2016 to get sober was no
it was not prissy i had to
in order to save my own life i it's
something i had to
and something that was different about
that time compared to every other time
is that i stopped leaning into that
shame i stopped leaning into that blame
i stopped leaning into that guilt even
though it was still there sort of like
an undercurrent i just started to get
curious
i just started to get curious what is
actually happening to me
on a brain based level when i drink in
this way why can't i just have one drink
why am i in this constant destructive
cycle
why when i stop drinking for a month
i start romanticizing alcohol again and
thinking that i will magically just
drink differently why do i make all of
these promises to myself and other
people but i can't keep them
why do i act like a completely different
person when i'm drunk i just started to
ask myself questions behavior-based
questions
um
and i'm someone that really loves to
read i'm a very curious person naturally
anyway so i just entered a world of
psychology a world of personal
development a world of and i mean we
have so much access to rich information
you don't even need to leave your your
room or your home to access some of
these things so i would just listen to
different teachers both ancient and
modern
and within that entire process i mean it
was about six months at that time when i
was intensely leaning into this new
information
but it was keeping me sober right
and i discovered the concept of
self-sabotage which to put it very
simply i mean it's it's kind of a very
layered thing but it's essentially when
you get in your own way
when you don't need someone else to pull
the plug you do it all yourself maybe
things are going well for a little while
and then you just get the urge
to [ __ ] it up
for whatever reason you just get this
urge to go back to what you know even if
what you know is very destructive you
just keep yourself in this cycle
and it was so beautiful because even
though
it meant i had to meet my shadow
i suddenly had new language for it so
instead of shaming myself back into
relapse i was able to start
saying okay so this is actually what i'm
experiencing so if i start to look at my
own experience in a more objective way
then i can actually change my behavior
and then that opened so many doors i was
invited onto different platforms to
share my story to speak to people
that were
addicts to speak to people that had been
sober for extended amounts of time to
speak to people that were my age i was i
was quite young
that were also going through the same
thing
and just through me sharing my own story
i then realized that
at some point it stopped being about me
and i had to turn this adversity into
something else so that i could support
other people that's when i started
getting trained in different
methodologies in coaching psychology
working with different mentors and i
just got so
immersed in
again curiosity but it wasn't about me
anymore i wanted to see how is
self-sabotage presenting itself for
other people and what part do things
like censorship play in it um and i was
speaking about self-censorship in the
context of
censoring your
own
life experiences censoring your own
thoughts censoring the shame that you
might have stopping yourself from saying
certain things it was still through just
the individual's behavior
and then
i'm gonna sort of speed it up so it
comes back to the now and then about two
years ago that's when i took the shift
from looking at it on a self-sabotage uh
sort of position into what i call
collective sabotage when i started to
notice certain things playing out in the
culture which i know we're going to be
talking about i realized oh my goodness
i've seen this before just in a
different way but now it's happening on
a mass level so my work has taken me
from looking at the individual and now
looking at the collective and i still do
both but that's how it sort of evolved
over time and it's what brings me here
that is fascinating
because i it's so true your experiences
kind of help you
to just see things in a bigger picture
and it helps it helps shift things a
little bit when you look at why do i why
am i thinking the way that i do why am i
doing the things that i do what what's
the reason behind it all
and then looking at it from a broader
perspective like why are so many of us
doing the things that we do as a
collective
yes it's fascinating and just being in
the world of social media we live a
completely different life than we did
when like we were growing up as children
before
instagram and twitter and facebook and
all those things even before youtube
largely took off and just
it's a completely different world now
it is it is and it feels like it's
happened
so quickly it feels like something has
really accelerated especially in the
past five years and i think it also
contributes to
just how we're
because all of this is relatively new at
the same time if you really think about
it so we're forcing ourselves to relate
to each other
on platforms on digital platforms that
don't really allow for that rich
communication to happen which is what i
believe is contributing to what i call
collective sabotage where we're forcing
ourselves our sort of primal selves to
operate in these environments that tend
to bring out our shadow mostly it's so
fascinating yes and act in ways that we
would never act in real life and say
things that
you know some people saying things that
they would just never say to someone in
real life like that's fascinating
and a lot of it has to do with like
a nominee am i saying that word
correctly
um hiding behind a screen it's easier to
say something when there's no
accountability behind it
and
and also i think we're living in a world
now where
people feel justified to quote-unquote
hold people accountable like that's a
thing now right and that kind of plays
into the whole topic of wokeness i think
it ties in really well together
i think your story is incredible for so
many reasons because i imagine that
maybe
six seven years ago you might have not
never even imagined what your world
would like look like now simply from
well it's i guess it wasn't a simple
process but from the mind shift within
yourself
yeah yeah you know i
every single year that i celebrate my
sober birthday
it always
i always feel so humbled by my new
reality in such a beautiful way because
what it reminds me which i think is also
very important for this conversation
is
the human animal's capacity for change
there was a time when i truly believed
that i i wasn't going to change this is
just who i am
when that couldn't have been further
from the truth and when i think about
the way that people are behaving towards
each other today for example this idea
that
you know some very ignorant statement
that you might have made on twitter 10
years ago is a full representation of
who you are today that you can't be
afforded change not only by yourself but
by the world right we're we're really
obsessed with the idea of the unchanged
human
and something that always grounds me and
my sobriety always brings me back to
even just all of these conversations
that seem unrelated um
is that i i am astounded just by how
much can change especially when you're
aware of that change which is why i push
back against a lot of what i see because
i think
the idea that people
can't consciously change i just find it
so absurd and having have lived it
myself and we all have every single
person listening to this
has
you're not the same person you were not
even two weeks ago and you probably
don't even agree with some things that
you said last year so why can we not
afford other people the same grace right
um
but yeah my my sobriety always keeps me
rooted in that i think
yeah i fully agree with that there's a
lot of things like qualities that my
husband has and i'll look at him and be
like wow
i could never be that way like he's just
so good at this and i'm i could i just
don't think like that but then the more
that i shift my mind and the more that i
work at it like i can change to be
towards more like these qualities that i
admire within someone else and
it puts you in a victor mentality when
you believe in yourself and you know
that you can change as opposed to like a
static this is who i am there's nothing
i can do to change
completely different your outcomes will
be completely different
i agree
so i wanted to ask you
you wrote this letter
leaving why i'm leaving the cult of
wokeness it's an open letter for those
of you who haven't
read it or heard of it i'll put the link
below in the show notes in the
description box but it's been
viewed by four million people now is
that right
yes now nearly five million which which
blows my entire mind i i mean
for a letter that is and it's not a
short one ellen i'm sure you know it's
it's not sure
but it's amazing and i recommend
everyone go listen to it
and
i wanted to read a quote from it so
people kind of have an idea like about
the topic within it of what what you're
getting at
and then i have some questions for you
about it
so something you said in here was
i can no longer be an active participant
in any culture or movement that
encourages group think outrage on demand
fear and violence revamp segregation
fabricating history history
cancellations masked as accountability
self-centeredness normalization of
racism towards white people the
disempowerment of black people masters
social justice the constant redefining
of existing language ignoring
self-responsibility constant
pathologizing oppressed versus oppressor
mentality and the pressure to conform
and comply it's exhausting and honestly
i have better things to do with my time
not to mention it's killing us
so i feel like that kind of helps people
know where are you going with this
letter and i recommend you read the
entire thing it's really incredible
but i wanted to ask you like what
brought you to
writing this open letter and why do you
think it's a cult of wokeness
right
i
you know what any time someone reads
even just a line from that letter back
to me i always get chills because i'm
transported to the exact moment that i
was sitting on my couch at 2am
on
i believe it was the last day of
december and then i published it on
january the 2nd 2021
and i remember exactly what i felt and
the main thing that i felt was
frustration
but there was also exhilaration along
with it because i felt like i was
finally removing probably the most
the heaviest layer of self-censorship
that i didn't even realize i had
until i sat down and allowed myself to
just write
which has always been one of the easiest
ways for me to really be honest with my
thoughts and what's happening internally
to just write but it wasn't
anything that i had ever publicly spoken
about before i think months before that
i had started to sort of express my
frustration in terms of what was
happening culturally
just this sort of
suffocating
environment everywhere you went where
you're supposed to pick a side where you
are you're either with us or you're
against us where certain questions are
just not allowed um but no one ever
tells you who who's making these
decisions it's almost like a social
agreement that you've just opted into um
almost like when you visit a website and
then you realize oh [ __ ] they took my
email and i didn't they didn't even ask
me
and then you just start getting
marketing materials it's kind of that's
kind of like how it felt
you know
um
mantras that i was just supposed to take
on and
ideas that were not supposed to be
questioned and even as i say this i'm
sure
someone listening just from me just
saying those pretty vague things for now
you kind of think yeah you you you get
what i'm talking about because of how
intense all of this stuff is but i think
to really um
to really kind of give a more clearer
answer
i think it's worth defining woke and
wokeness
right because i think there are
differences so i yeah i was gonna yes i
was gonna ask you that totally
right because
i i think
i think ellen sometimes when these
conversations happen everyone has
different ideas of what certain words
mean and these are quite loaded terms
especially now
so i always find it so useful when there
are just clear definitions and if you
were to ask someone else they might say
something different
but this is the way that i was coming at
it from so the origins of the word work
originally it's a term that started from
the u.s black america particularly and
it's a very important and meaningful
term for black people in the us and now
it's sort of spread into the
anglo-sphere
but by definition it was the state of
being aware so being aware of things
like racism and just inequality in
general and you know again a very
important and useful term especially at
that time in the 60s in the 70s 80s even
to the 90s
but
like with most things that start with a
good intention somewhere along the line
they do get co-opted by people
sometimes even well-intentioned people
that end up taking things way too far
right
and
now wokeness itself in the present day
2021
it's become more so of an ideology and
within that ideology you have the
extremes of identity politics where you
have hierarchy hierarchies that are
based on identity markers that for
example if you are white you can't have
a say on race um which i just think is
[ __ ] ridiculous we're all racialized
people and you know if we want to find a
way to bring unity we need to be able to
to
talk and we need to be able to have the
uncomfortable conversations but you know
there are these
hierarchies that you can't even question
um you have things like performative
activism where people think you know
just a
six slide infographic is going to change
the world well i'm sorry to tell you
that i i don't think that's how that's
how it works and you get to
dox people online if you don't agree
with them you get to shame people in the
comments sections or in twitter threads
um where binary thinking is encouraged
again that pro or anti black or white
with us or against us there's just no
regard for nuance um
and also it always looks like a
competition to outwork the other person
so because of that environment where
wokeness in the present day has become
like a religion like an ideology and
some really wonderful thinkers from all
sides of the political spectrum speak
about this very very well i think it's
just worth looking into the sort of
parallels that people
um are laying out to really understand
this pretty new phenomenon if you will
but what that does is that it creates an
environment where people are just
terrified it creates an environment
where people end up
you know just feeling that it's much
safer to self-censor because they've
seen what happens to others when they
ask questions they've seen what happens
when you point out a contradiction
they've seen what happens when you're
not you know equipped with all of the
latest and ever-changing new terminology
and you say something that maybe other
people consider outdated and before you
know it maybe you've lost your job maybe
you're being publicly shamed you're
being misrepresented it's a very hostile
environment and as we were saying
because a lot of it is taking place
digitally
it's really hard to control there's no
there's no center there's no um goal in
mind
so
all of that taken into account
even as a black person
which
by you know by the tenets of this
ideology i am somewhere up high on the
hierarchy regardless and it doesn't
matter whether my character is good it
doesn't matter what my values actually
are what i actually stand for is just
about the color of my skin it's just
that you're black it's because you're
black there before that's it that's it
right
and
slight it's not even a tangent actually
it's really important for this something
else that i know is that my letter has
been able to reach so many people as in
they've been able to receive my words
and i've i haven't received any pushback
for my letter
it's because i'm black that people are
willing to listen
right someone else could have said and
people have very similar things just
looking at it very objectively but
because we're in a time where people
have decided that actually you're black
so you get to say this but i'm not
saying the things that
i should be saying right i'm saying
things that actually contradict a lot of
these things so it kind of causes a lot
of cognitive dissonance which just shows
you
the design of all of this right right i
mean also you're very eloquent and you
speak in a way that's very easy for
people to grasp and understand where
you're coming from
so
yeah there's that let's let's
there is definitely that i mean of
course yeah no but i fully i fully know
what you're saying i mean and you and i
come from opposite realms of the
spectrum of what we're experiencing
on social media in realms of topics like
this and my husband my husband really
enjoys discourse and he will
do it online whereas i i don't enjoy it
online like i want to do it face to face
i want to have a conversation in person
but he doesn't mind doing it online so
there's times when he'll engage and i
and if someone disagrees with him i kid
you not i am not joking every single
time
they jump to well you're just a straight
white man every single time no matter
because if they can't argue his points
if they can't argue what he has to say
they jump to
what he looks like in his identity right
because he's a straight white man and
and something he's said back before is
could you imagine if i said to you you
wouldn't understand because you're a
black man like no
you would never say that so we've come
to this place online that
is disgusting to me and i've actually
never and obviously this isn't
everywhere this isn't always it's like a
certain
certain realm of there's certain
how do i say it
it's sometimes with some people it's not
all it's not always right like we should
be clear right but it's gotten really
overwhelming
to a point where where i feel like we're
just like not seeing the humanity within
people and i don't
and i don't agree i agree with what
you're saying that i i don't think that
we should only assign
um weight to someone's opinions based on
their identity or based on if they're
within the group of the topic we're
talking about like for instance i don't
think men can't have an opinion about
abortion like to me that doesn't make
sense because
you know
the argument is that because they're not
a woman because they haven't gone
through it but let's just argue their
arguments as opposed to just saying
nothing you say matters because you're a
man like i to me that's not that's not
interesting to me it's much more
interesting
to discuss the position and the and the
arguments and the points than it is to
just shut someone down based on their
gender their sex their identity
and their race
yeah oh i everything you just said is so
important to be heard out loud because
you know even when you also say that
it's not happening all the time
everywhere that is 100
true
and also
this anti-social behavior which is what
it is
is spreading like wildfire and it's
important to even refer to it as
anti-social behavior because i think
people shut down when they hear if i had
said instead of this work behavior and i
don't speak in that way
because even though my letter is called
why i'm leaving the cult of wokeness if
someone asks me what is wokeness i will
give you that definition of how i see it
as an ideology but i will also respect
its origins because i'm i'm equipped to
hold multiple truths and i'm also
realistic about what what it is now and
also because even using that term people
will know what it means
but in discussion
i don't think it's useful to just
use work as a catch-all for everything i
think it's much more useful to use very
specific language and it means that
people don't shut down and it's also it
also just drives home what's really
happening so anti-social behavior is
what we're seeing cyber bullying
is what a lot of this is it's just must
um
it's just really wrapped in social
justice language and you have people
that can do that very very well which is
frightening but then it starts to spread
as if this is just the normal way of
relating to each other but it's a very
it's a very hostile environment and
that's what drove me to write the letter
and
the way that i've seen
it inspire other people to just start
having the conversation and not even
publicly just privately because another
disturbing thing about this ellen i
don't know if you've seen this in your
own life
is that it's not isolated social media
or the digital world in terms of how
it's affecting people in the real world
people are finding it very challenging
to have
even the simplest conversations or to
just ask a question
yes fully i mean because of their
experience that they've seen online and
what happens when you ask questions
especially
with everything that happened in 2020
about blm and everything
it was so extreme that i think people
started to
started to definitely self-censor even
in their own lives and real in real life
and i think it's a really good point
that you brought brought up about
wokeness being something originally
different and what it's like turned into
because i think you're right from the
beginning it was a good idea it's really
good to be awake and aware but like
being aware of like where did it take a
turn and what's happening now
because this obsession that is had
online with
terms and labels and
jumping to conclusions when someone says
something that you don't like
or that you think isn't exactly perfect
yeah that's what i have a problem with
yeah
right it's um
the self-righteousness
the self-righteousness and actually i
shared something the other day that i
would just love to read to you very
quickly it's not long at all and i think
for me this really summarizes some of
what we're saying right now um
so what i wrote was
i am not anti-woke be as woke as you
like
in fact we need more people to be awake
that can only be a good thing
but what we are seeing collectively
today is far from progressive it's
regressive and disturbing i'm all for
people wanting to create a better world
i'm all for people calling out genuine
injustice what i'm not for is extremism
in any form entitlement denial of
reality in favor of an imagined utopia
that's my favorite part
the demands to pick aside and division
must as progress that's where you lose
me
and for me that just summarizes that i'm
not taking a position as being anti-woke
i have no interest in that i'm
interested in
the nuance i and my one of my friends
put it very
well the other day he was saying that
he's pro-nuance he's not anything else
he's just pro-nuance and that's the
position that i will willingly you know
assign myself to because
i i just want to find the middle ground
again i think we we have forgotten that
there is a gray area that we can all
step in we exist in it anyway um so
that's that's what i'm more interested
in and really just putting boundaries
and saying no i'm not playing whatever
game this is i choose not to play it
yeah i mean
i i feel like it would be good for us to
share personal experiences within this
because what you said is so good i've
definitely liked that post that you
wrote i probably reshared it
yes but but i have to be honest i have
not gotten into
much
online uh expression with this topic in
particular because of
because of exactly what we just talked
about because of the identity wrapped up
into it and
knowing that the way that people receive
things and that's actually one of the
reasons why i started the podcast
because
i'm a person that loves conversations
and words and i never felt that found
that small instagram caption limit to be
enough to really fully express what i
wanted to say and how i felt
because
my goal is for people to just understand
where i'm coming from and i really don't
like to be misunderstood so then as a
result i just self-censored you know and
i have my
my youtube channel where i it's like a
vlog channel and i never felt like that
was the right space either where people
are looking for these small
sound bite entertainment clips right
like 20 minutes as opposed to
like a long nuanced conversation
and so that's why i started the podcast
initially and that's why i'm like i'm
ready because i i feel confident to talk
about these topics that i care about
like you've seen talked about my earlier
episodes i'm speaking on topics i
haven't talked about before because i'm
like this feels comfortable i can share
how i really feel and it feels good
inside to share how
where i'm coming from and to fully
express it you know yes oh i hear you
and
um
this also speaks to actually the
platforms in which we're trying to have
certain conversations because even just
when i think of instagram is the only
social media that i have but it
originally started as and it still is a
visual platform right it wasn't really
about writing or anything like that
although it's more so of a video
platform as well um
but
it's very difficult to
first of all really get all of the
nuance of what you're trying to say and
distill it into a caption as you're
saying but another thing about it is
that
when you're with someone face to face
you can see their body language you can
gauge their tonality delivery is easier
to really understand because of all of
those other things that are playing a
part in that communication process it's
not a fragmented process it's so whole
there's so much happening so
even when you're with someone that you
disagree with on a specific thing it's
much easier to have that exchange when
you're face to face but we're trying to
do it in a way that doesn't really work
you know if if you're having a back and
forth with someone on a comment section
on instagram it's not possible to re it
doesn't work it doesn't work right it
doesn't um
so i like what you're saying because
this is why i also love podcasts and
doing things like instagram lives
because it allows me to open so many
different doors it allows me to play
around with my tonality and my delivery
and to not try and make it you know a
two minute get everything in two minutes
or get everything in five minutes um and
i something that i also do ellen which
maybe might be useful to you or someone
listening
is that
i
stay away from anything that is current
news ish i i just won't go there
i
if i see something that i feel very
strongly about maybe i will share or if
i say something hilarious maybe i will
share because i love to laugh uh but i
won't be a social commentator in that
sense because i think that's when it's
it can be very easy
to find yourself feeding into this
political machine
and
i've seen a lot of people ending up
stepping into it without even wanting to
but then you get stuck in it and then it
becomes a whole thing some so what i do
i think about the bigger picture and the
bigger message which is why i just love
the fact that everything i talk about
today
still ties into the two pillars that
i've been looking at for the past five
years self-sabotage and self-censorship
because i think to myself okay what is
the bigger picture what am i trying to
speak about am i trying to speak about
division
am i trying to speak about how we need
to humanize one another again am i
trying to speak about
why we need to
you know
cultivate the capacity to hold multiple
truths am i trying to speak about how
we've lost the ability to communicate so
these are things that are still quite
broad but very specific enough and i
think that's much more useful
than trying to
uncensor yourself so that you can
you know get some controversial thoughts
out
without knowing what your ultimate
intention with that is which is why i
always say to people
i recommend if you are going through a
conscious process of undoing
self-censorship don't even think about
social media don't even think about your
podcast don't even think about putting
it out into the public sphere you need
to first
get rid of the mob in your own mind
that's not step number one because we're
at a point now and i'm getting chills as
i think about it we've come to a point
where
the self-censorship is so deeply
ingrained now
that we consult the mob in our minds
before we even make a decision
and that's wild so it's not about social
media or what you're going to say there
that will be a byproduct of a more
silent and intimate process
oh my gosh you made such a good point
there
actually almost all the time all the
time i'm about to post something or i'm
writing something and i'm keeping in
mind what will i'm not saying it in
those words like what will the mom say
but it's like what will someone have to
say to criticize this and how can i word
this to be better understood or just to
be less inflammatory and to be
right like i i so do that i do that all
the time all the time and
no go ahead
no no no i i was going to say i think
that's not always necessarily a
quote-unquote bad thing because i think
there's something useful there the fact
that you're not um
reactionary right you want to actually
respond to the action that you want to
take
right so i think you can take something
useful from that and say actually i
should consider the way in which and i i
do this also i should consider how i
present this maybe this is a prickly
topic what's the best way to approach
this again you don't want to uh get
sucked into that too much you also want
to take a risk a little bit it's the
risk piece that's it's the balance right
it's the balance
yes whereas what you're speaking about
earlier is maybe someone who's too
afraid to ever say what they really
think or what they want to say
if it's even remotely controversial
right and i'm so glad you brought up the
fact that online having an online
presence now the thing about like should
we be talking about real world events or
current events i feel like there's a
pressure nowadays i don't know maybe in
your realm but in the realm i'm in for
sure
there's a pressure to speak on any
remotely big current event and to
publicly talk about it and to publicly
say your stance and to publicly vouch
for it or be an activist for it
and that could be
a wide range of topics like i get
messages whenever something blows up in
the media and what i find interesting is
that there's all different kinds of news
stories there's lots of
hurt and troubles and and just horrible
things happening in the world but
whenever something takes hold on
instagram
and they see everyone else they're
following posting about it that's when
people start going to like pages like me
like why aren't you talking about this
you need to be talking about this why
aren't you posting about this this
business and i i mean there's more i can
say multiple multiple events even
something as far as like the australia
fires i'm not in australia and when the
australian fires are why aren't you
talking about australia fires and the
climate change
and or things like um
something that might be more relevant to
me is even like what is more relevant to
is the fact that i'm in hawaii is things
like talking about mauna kea and
the um
um hawaiian rights type aspect of things
with mauna kea so but it's
and then it came to george floyd as well
and
obviously and then we can get into that
that aspect i think that'll be really
interesting
for us to share our personal experiences
during what happened with like in 2020
because it's obviously going to be quite
different
and i think that's really helpful for
people to just see
how divisive it's become
and
and when it comes to the world events
like i've always come from a place where
i'm i'm not going to be pressured to
post about anything i don't feel
inclined or passionate to post about yes
or if i don't feel well educated on
something enough i'm not going to just
speak on it to just be able to say look
i spoke about it look i care like that's
not me i'm going to post
what i feel passionate about and what i
want to post like nothing someone else
can no one can pressure me to post about
something to just feel accepted or to
not be like um
shamed
yeah
yes and you know what i love those
boundaries because that's what they are
we we
have created a culture
which is so multi-layered but one of
those layers is the idea that the
digital world that you don't really need
boundaries that people can just sort of
step into your if you think of your
instagram account for example your page
as your home that any stranger can step
in and just [ __ ] shout at you any
time they want and make a demand and
you're just supposed to do it that if
you put a post out you have to make sure
that you're catering to the
sensibilities and triggers and nuanced
experiences of 500 million users per day
it's it doesn't make any sense so one of
the things that i found to be really
important is that you have to set the
terms of engagement yourself which is
what i've just heard you do right i'm
not going to be pressured into speaking
i will only speak about what i know
about i think should be the first point
because a lot of people are being forced
or feeling as if you know their hand has
been forced to speak about things they
have no idea about i think one of the
most recent ones was when
everything was happening in palestine
and israel
and people were being shouted at for not
talking about it for not saying
something
but
you do realize that people
are on this platform from all corners of
the globe so should someone in zimbabwe
be taught should they know all of the
nuanced details of what's happening in
the middle east but that same person
could come and shout at everyone online
and say why you're not talking about
what's happening in zimbabwe there's
been an ongoing war in ethiopia as well
yeah why should there's something
happening everywhere and everywhere all
the time
something that i always say ellen is
that
usually those same people that are you
know waltzing through the streets of
instagram or wherever it is shouting at
everyone they probably don't even know
what's happening in their local
community
they probably have no idea what's
happening in the local community are
they supporting the people that live
next door to them
yeah but it's because social media told
them to care about this one particular
thing and then that means they have to
talk about it and that's not to say let
me be clear that's not to say that those
things don't matter they do but what
what upsets or not upset but what is
just confusing to me
is
how
easily we jump on this bandwagon of like
this is the only thing that matters
right now and everyone needs to talk
about it even if you don't actually know
fully know all the details
or you don't have anything of really
importance or value to add to the
conversation not to mention we're not
news outlets we're not journalists like
this isn't don't expect everybody to say
things
on a topic or else they're a bigot or
they're this or that like that's just
unrealistic
right and this falls under the
performative activism right because it's
it seems like it's just a performance
because what is that actually going to
change and you know people could
obviously argue it's awareness and i
think within context and if it's done in
a consensual way
then yes i think you're raising
awareness in a
powerful important way but it's not
happening in that way it's happening
through guilting and shaming people and
threatening to de-platform people that
don't perform on demand and i think
that's the
it's it's again anti-social behavior
that is just being normalized and
wrapped up in social justice language
and we have to say no and i i'm really
glad that you're saying what you're
saying because i think
more people
should be willing to say actually no i'm
i i will do things as i need to and it's
also unethical to just pass around
information that could possibly be
untrue yes
like yes
absolutely and not to mention that
there's so much nuance to so many of
these big world events too it's not as
black and white as social media wants to
make it seem not always but a lot of
times so let's how about we get into
specifically what happened during george
floyd blm with your personal experience
and mike's i think that would be really
fascinating do you want to go first or
should i
um
how about you like you too actually oh
oh me okay okay
okay
you know why is it you know why i said
that because
usually when i speak to people about
2020 especially in a in an exchange like
this one they're usually asking me what
my experience was and i think you
normally get to hear from for example
black people because it would sort of
make sense to want to ask the black
people oh so what did you experience
and of course the the high emotions that
people felt especially last year and the
way that it sort of ended by the end of
the year that level of polarization
which i don't think we've ever really
seen as of late um
it felt as though and i mean i've spoken
to so many people at this point in time
thousands it felt as though and people
were being told that if you're white
you shouldn't feel anything it's so it's
so bizarre that you shouldn't feel upset
or confused or even or even you're not
allowed to have an experience even just
me
even me saying i had an experience is
like you're deflecting you're deflecting
from the problem this is you're trying
to make it about you and this is not
about you and right i fully get that but
i am so much meaning as applied to just
you saying hey i i have an experience
yes but like i am
not afraid to just say this is how i
feel this is what i experienced
especially i feel comfortable like i
said because i'm on this this podcast
platform where we're having just a full
conversation whereas i've never i've
never actually
done an instagram post about this ever
so why is that and it's because like we
said earlier there just isn't enough
room for nuance and discussion on an
instagram post
yeah if that makes sense it does make
sense it does make sense so i think
that's why i'm um
really curious to hear what your
experience of it was okay
so everything happened with george floyd
all all obvious sorry obviously what
happened was horrendous and horrible and
actually i don't even know a single
person who would defend what happened to
george floyd as okay no one
um i had just given birth to my fourth
baby of a couple weeks ago i think and
so i was in like baby land in my own
home
every once in a while getting online
something my husband mentioned something
about
george floyd and stuff and just
learning about what happened
and
rarely online myself though
and then i slowly see this
incoming of
comments coming on my latest picture of
my baby kofax hundreds of comments like
starting to come in saying
why aren't you talking about george
floyd why aren't you talking about blm
why haven't you done a black square
you're a white supremacist you're a
neo-nazi you're all these things when i
hadn't
said
a single thing i hadn't said
anything and it was because i hadn't
said anything it had been probably like
six seven days now after the fact and
everyone's posting like everyone is
posting about
george floyd and blm every single day
it's really the only thing that was on
online that i was seeing it was the only
thing and if you posted something that
wasn't that it was like what are you
doing you know so i just like decided to
just take a step back and just not
post anything just looking observing
type of thing
but seeing it just slowly come in
by the hundreds thousands like that and
the arguments on this post of my baby
i'm like
i don't know if i ever want to post a
picture of my children ever again like
that just made me like the and also
i understand what like maybe people
listening is going this isn't about you
try stop making this about you this is
not what i'm saying i'm not trying to
make it about me at all it was more just
my experience on how i chose to respond
and
i don't have the typical
viewpoints of
what maybe they wanted me to post
like and maybe they hadn't even
considered that there was another
idea around
what was happening not to say
right like i don't even know how to word
this totally
like in the best way but
i'm not saying that what happened to him
was right of course not like police
brutality in any form i'm against that
completely it's what came after that
with with all of the
the hashtags and all of the just
everything that happened i don't even
know how much i should get into it but i
just don't hold the same type of
mentality about like
like for instance well anyways one of
someone online i guess they were people
a lot of people were starting to go to
other vegan influencers who were black
and saying like you need to go you need
to put ellen in line she's not saying
anything
she's you need to get her like put her
straight because she's not talking about
this she's not saying
blm and then one of them
came to me and was like hey someone said
you weren't posting anything and i was
like she isn't i kind of like that
because he was like i everyone is i
heart i'm not because i don't hold the
same
type of
perspective that people would typically
and so it was refreshing to see maybe
you're not sharing this like
regurgitated what everyone's telling you
to do
right as opposed to like just thinking
critically
so i ended up posting like
you know my husband was like don't and
ellen don't say anything but i was like
i'm gonna i'm gonna just like make it
clear so people know like obviously i
don't agree with what happened to him
because it was just nothing had been so
blown up right compared to this out of
all the other news stories i had
mentioned this was the biggest that it
ever happened so i like put it on my
stories like i just want to make it
clear like you know how long it's been
like of course what happened to him was
wrong and horrible and should never
happen police brutality is wrong and
evil completely against that and then i
just shared something after like
um i also think it's important to listen
to like all different voices and to not
just like assume there's like a monolith
of like exactly one idea
and i have a friend
who was like interested in having her
opinions shared but she doesn't have a
big platform but she was also a little
bit nervous for me to maybe be like
go follow this person because she knows
of kind of like the bash class she could
get for sharing a different opinion as a
black woman and so she's like just have
them dm you
if they're interested and then you can
send a dm to the person but that was we
did that but that was really hard for me
to like keep up with like sending people
anyway so that was the gist of my story
and then people go oh i can't believe
she would say that there's a different
opinion to this there's one opinion i
can't she's this this or that just like
a a flood of
you're a neo-nazi a white supremacist
you're a bigot blah blah blah so that
that was basically
that was basically what happened i'm so
sorry you experienced that oh it's okay
i don't i don't feel any kind of
well
i just don't i understand what you think
i i understand what you mean um yeah but
it's also important for me to say it's
it's not okay because i hear so many
stories like that especially about
everything that people experienced in in
2020 and not just white people but from
black people as well from brown people
from people that really wanted to take
the time to understand the situation
instead of looking at a headline from
people that acknowledged just how vile
um what had happened to him was but how
there were also other things that we
weren't aware of that were being shown
you know
just a very short story of a much much
much much more layered situation
but again that wasn't welcome and those
people some people even had their entire
livelihoods destroyed
just because they did echo right just
because they didn't echo
what they were told they were supposed
to and and the
another thing that's really disturbing
about this is that
some of the people that may be
you know joined in on your
cancellation campaign if you will if you
were to walk past them in the street you
wouldn't even know who who the person is
and i emphasize that because it's
strangers that have a this much of a
hold so it's important for me to
actually that it's not normal behavior
it's not okay we've normalized it and
because you're white i'm supposed to say
oh
yeah that's just that's just how it is
yeah and if you care about it then
you're just yes you're just showing your
white fragility and you're right
sensitive yeah but but really i was just
seeing so many things online happening
that made zero sense to me the obsession
with with with oh man where do i begin
the the obsession was saying you need to
say something but then if you said
something you didn't say that right
or if you or you need to listen to black
people and then if you say okay i'm here
listening share what you want how dare
you make us do the work and tell you
what you think like too many things just
contradicted each other and didn't make
any sense
and
yeah
and i think okay so the last thing i
want to say before you go into yours is
that the main core thing for me is that
not all black people feel like they're
oppressed and this whole monolith that
like black people are oppressed white
people are the oppressor black people
can't get ahead in life and they can't
they can't get to where they want in
life because they're black not everybody
not every black person thinks that way
so why is this the norm and why do you
have to say that or else you're a bigot
that does not make sense to me and i
think so many people just weren't
considering that and also if somebody
was saying hey
i don't feel oppressed i'm not oppressed
i'm black and i don't feel oppressed
they say oh you're internalized racism
none of that makes sense to me
none of that makes sense to me so for me
there was like such a lack of critical
thinking and that's that's where i was
coming from and so yeah people didn't
like that
thank you so much for sharing that it is
so refreshing
just to hear someone
especially someone who is in the public
eye like you are being willing
to just say what they experienced you're
not giving you know a kind of abstract
opinion on something hypothetical this
is just something that happened in the
summer of 2020 hey
right but the the fact that
again because of these identity markers
we have decided who can share their
experience and who can't but at the same
time we've seem to value lived
experience but only the lived experience
of those that towed the line and say
what we say and follow this very
particular script so it's just
so many contradictions and
i
saw everything that you just said
in terms of what happened to you and
what you observed
is what i was seeing myself but just in
a very different way
so i am in the uk
and i am an immigrant from zimbabwe came
to the uk at the age of nine from africa
and i'm now 29 so i've lived most of my
life here uh but i'm not in the us
and here in the uk even though we have
of course i mean there's so much um so
much history that we could get into but
we won't in terms of the part the uk has
played
um you know in colonizing and the race
conversations that have been
had here as well but it's very different
to america it's not the same at all but
in the summer of 2020 when everything
happened with george floyd and i think
something had happened with i i
not able to remember the name maybe
jacob blake i think
um
there was this idea
that we are just supposed to
take on everything that is happening in
the us
as if it's also what's happening here in
the uk
that you can't point out just how
different our experiences of race are
that you just have to look at the color
of your skin and you have to look at
this very big story that is happening in
another country and you have to take it
on as your own
and i did i did
and i briefly fell into that and again
we we have fully acknowledged that what
happened should not have happened
regardless of what his history was what
his criminal record was et cetera it
doesn't justify the way that he was
taken it just doesn't absolutely um
right and
it was such a highly emotional time and
i think also lockdown played a part in
this because i think if people weren't
in their homes on their phones 24 7 in
the way that we were i think things
would have looked a little bit different
so i i'd be curious to see in the years
to come
the kind of research and studies that
are done on how the lockdown has
influenced some of the biggest shifts in
our culture
but it was a highly emotional time
and
we were
being sold this idea that black people
in in america but it could be anywhere
you are in the world are being hounded
in the streets and that the comedy
common enemy is any white person
any white person that is the common
enemy that there are only two sides
you're either the oppressor
and to be the oppressor the minimum is
that you're white and that's it you're
assigned that role and to be oppressed
the very minimum is that you're a black
person and that is your assigned role
but i never bought into that i never
bought into that that's when i felt
myself
thinking i don't buy into this but why
do i feel
scared to say that i don't buy into this
like it's a very
i don't think all white people are
my oppressor because i i'd have to think
i'm oppressed to think there's an
oppressor i've never felt oppressed in
my entire life the color of my skin is
not a burden have i experienced elements
of racism yes especially my childhood
but
some of the rejection that i have
experienced because of my blackness has
been from other black people so that's
another element of my race and my
experience and it has
it looks different from person to person
so again all of these different
questions and kind of wait this doesn't
apply to me
i felt like i couldn't say it and i'm a
very confident and outspoken person and
i've always been but it felt like there
was this no-go area but it's not as if
someone told me that i can't talk about
it it's like a societal decision that
has been made on my behalf
and that was just one of the moments
where the veneer started to crack for me
and when i started to see the level of
um dehumanization
where
people's
again
the exact same thing that happened to
you people's comment sections and their
photos being swarmed
you know people pretty much the mob just
knocking on your door saying why haven't
you shared this very specific thing that
i think is important why are you not
chanting this exact same message why are
you not condemning yourself because of
your race because a lot of white people
are being told to apologize
or you need to apologize to any black
friends you have but i am a black friend
to many people but i was thinking but i
i don't
want my friends to apologize to me from
having power over me it was just so
strange
um so as much as i was
experiencing that unity with other black
people and in mourning which i thought
was actually important and still do
there was also another side of me that
was thinking okay but now this is going
into the extreme
and it's going into a very very dark
place
but i felt that i'm betraying the
movement if i say something about this
um but then the self-censorship just got
very very strong and i started to see it
in other areas it wasn't just about race
anymore it was anywhere we can find the
division let's find it that that's
that's the game that started to get
created
and again that's what added to me ending
up writing that letter but it's it's
just so interesting and refreshing to
hear your side of it because i saw that
happen
from the outside and i was being told
that i'm supposed to be okay with that
yeah i think because it was so
bombarding it was everywhere
and so it's intimidating
you know like i consider myself a very
confident um outspoken person as well
but in that moment i'm like i'm
i'm gonna not say anything i'm gonna
just right you know i'm gonna make it
clear like my stance on like police
brutality obviously and then i'm done
because
yeah
i i saw so many people apologizing
when it felt
not genuine and people just attacking
other people it just got to such a crazy
place like so many so many layered
things as well
even what are your thoughts on
like things like um the whole uplift
black voices thing because
i saw over and over like these are black
businesses to support and like sing
and i find that such an interesting
interesting conversation because like
let's just say devil's advocate here
like
couldn't that considered couldn't that
be considered like
why
that means i'm only being supported
because i'm black um my business is
successful because i'm black as opposed
to because it's a good business
right right like these
yeah these are conversations that are
actually
and i think this is such a good thing
these are conversations that have been
happening i think since the since
everyone sort of stepped out of the haze
that was 2020 and people
generally did start to think okay
maybe this one a little bit too far and
started to review
their own behavior and just some of the
things that were happening
these are some of the conversations that
are starting to happen while where i am
at least um
in the uk just amongst black people
generally to
say actually i don't want to be
i don't need my voice to be uplifted
just because of my skin color is what
i'm saying of value yes and exactly as
you're saying is my business actually a
good business and it just so happens
that i'm black right yes because it's
it's one of those things again where i
understand i can say that i understand
the intention behind it right looking at
the people that are most um
underrepresented and uplifting those
people but then when does it become a
little bit or a lot infantilizing as if
you're sort of just saying ah just just
give them something you know let's just
you you're not that great but just we
just need this to die down
to me it just ends up being again that
performative activism almost which
doesn't seem to have a very specific
goal
but i think they are things that start
very much well in tension but a lot of
people myself included
i i don't want you to do me any favors
because of the color of my skin i know
that i'm very good at what i do
and if i had let's say a brick and
mortar shop i want you to be there
because my products are actually good
and the service is actually good not
because of the color of my skin so i
think what we saw in 2020
you had a lot of people including
corporations sort of scrambling to prove
that they're not racist or kind of
scrambling to prove that social justice
is a big value for them and in that
process they end up infantilizing the
very people they're trying to represent
and i think
a lot of people bought into it at the
time and maybe still do because you
still see it but i think now more people
realize that actually it's not really
doing the many favors
um in terms of the long term so i think
it's definitely a worthy conversation
it's definitely a worthy question yes
yes because i understand like what
you're saying i understand the
intentions behind it of uplifting
a certain community and stuff yeah but
you end up you end up painting an entire
group of people as a certain way
as needing to be helped and it's like a
soft bigotry of low expectations that's
it that's exactly it
and
i think people just aren't some people
just aren't considering that there's
that's why the nuance and the
conversation is so important and that's
why we're talking about this because we
we've heard
all the other perspectives here like
we've all heard it but like let's hear
this as well that could be could be
given a little bit more light it helps
find a nuance and a balance you know i
agree yeah
okay i also i feel like for me another a
personal experience of like what you
said how people will assume maybe you
want to be treated a certain way or that
you maybe you feel oppressed when you
don't i've gotten that too about like
being a woman like people saying well
don't you want people to acknowledge
that like you're suffering or that you
haven't been able to get as far ahead
because you're a woman and my honest
opinion is that i've never felt
oppressed as a woman i've never felt
like i was less than or couldn't get as
far ahead as a woman if anything it's
the opposite if anything are today's
culture i feel like it's easier as a
woman
but that's just my personal experience
obviously not everybody's going to have
that experience but
yeah
yeah and you know
i love this conversation and i'm
actually so excited to listen back
because this is one this is one of the
things that i put very briefly in my
open letter
but it was specifically referring to why
i don't call myself a feminist i mean i
do have
values that can align with feminism
but
probably not whatever this version of
feminism is that we have today in 2021
but it's not a label that i use for
myself it's not a label that i need
culturally as a
zimbabwean person it's just not in our
language right but through actions we do
want equality between the sexes between
the genders women are upheld
and just like you i never grew up
thinking my girlhood or my womanhood is
a burden am i aware of the things that
happen to women all over the world
absolutely and in fact i would feel as
if
i'm slapping
the women that are truly oppressed in
the face for me to sit here in the
western world and say that i'm
oppressed i i really i really would
because i'm aware of what true
oppression looks like something that i
really advocate for
um
is
survivors that have experienced fgm
which is female genital mutilation which
is a practice that happens quite a lot
in africa also asia also here in um
in the uk as well a little bit
but
i know what oppression actually looks
like
and because
from what i see is that there seems to
be this sort of um
you put on a pedestal the more
victimized that you are
and there's a culture of just keeping
people terrified and i think it's
keeping women so scared when they're
constantly told that you being a woman
you're always going to have it less that
you should always
you know look out and see where there's
a gender pay gap or where there's a gap
somewhere that you're not fitting into
or a way that you're disadvantaged
etc and it's just creating a
another layer of that culture of keeping
people so terrified and just in constant
victimhood and i say that not to say
that women are not experiencing really
things that we could we couldn't
possibly imagine
but we also need to be willing to hear
the women that say actually i'm a woman
and i don't feel oppressed there is that
side to our experience as well
but for whatever reason it seems as if
you
can't even say that because it means
something it's like you're denying or
it's misogynistic
yes in some strange way it's so bizarre
you hit the nail on the head so so
amazingly there because it is true there
are women that are truly suffering and
are truly being oppressed across the
world and it does feel like a disservice
to just say that i'm oppressed and also
i think whatever you see
whatever you think you see that will be
your reality what you say to yourself
especially in the western world we do
have equal rights and we do have the
privileges that we do today that if you
are constantly being told you're
oppressed you're oppressed you're
oppressed whether it be because if
you're a woman or because of the color
of your skin or because of your gender
identity
if the more that you say it the more
that you will see it even in places that
it doesn't exist yes and that's not
saying that you won't have certain
experiences that
that are
that could define that but if it if you
let it define you that's where it shifts
how you put out put out your life into
the world and how you how you feel
inside so that's not to say that maybe
i've never experienced like i have
experienced like certain things because
i'm a woman or the way that i look right
like in the workplace back when i was a
waitress like things like that but
how that defines me is where you move
forward like if that defines me or not
right you know right yeah oh that's so
you've put that so beautifully because
when people
really decide that they're going to tune
into selective hearing which is what i
see in kind of this workness ideology if
you will um that you can say something
even just as you said so specifically
and so intentionally and people will
just filter through that and take
different words together and put them
together and say oh so this is what
you're trying to say i know and that's
right so difficult that's why it is
difficult to put yourself online like
this yeah and that's why your work is so
fascinating because you're helping teach
people
to come into their own power and speak
where they're really coming from that's
why it's so powerful and also we should
actually get into about how important
the collective is that's where you're
coming from and how right you want to
explain a little bit how about the work
that you do is like largely about the
collective
yes absolutely so i mentioned before
that the origins of my work is just
really understanding self-sabotage so as
the time would suggest it's really about
the individual how can you look at your
own behavior how is your behavior
impacting the results that you actually
start to get
how is your internal world influencing
the way you think and the actions that
you take or don't take etc
um
but now it's evolved into me just
wanting to understand
collectively what are we doing right now
and something that i come back to is
personal responsibility
i don't know if this is something you
would have spoken about when you spoke
to zooby but personal responsibility is
something that seems to be demonized
currently people seem to think it's
synonymous with victim blaming almost
which is another term that has become
you know kind of um
taken people's fancy but when i think of
collective sabotage i just see it as a
group of individuals that instead of
taking personal responsibility and
looking at what they can control and
looking at how they can shift their own
behavior so they can start to get their
desired results where they learn how to
sit with their own discomfort they don't
do any of that they just think this is
what is happening to me right now it's
uncomfortable and i'm experiencing
something i don't like so therefore
something outside of me is the problem i
don't have to look at any of that
the system is the problem and here's the
thing because i know some people will
will you know try to fill in the gaps
here but i acknowledge the systems that
we live under i wrote this in my letter
i can i'm able to hold multiple truths i
can acknowledge that there are systems
that need to change and at the same time
as an individual there are things that
are within your control right and for
you to be able to tune into that you
have to take responsibility for them you
have to take accountability for some of
those things you have to make different
decisions
so with that being said we're now
starting to see
that it's become sort of like a social
norm to project any discomfort that
you're feeling internally so why i call
it collective sabotage is that it's no
longer just about the individual that we
have to be concerned about we now have
groups of these people that find each
other and sort of just project all of
their internal discomfort or their
dissatisfaction with the world um and
this kind of their chase for a utopia
that will never exist and then it
becomes everyone else's problem and they
don't have to look at it and because of
social media and the digital world
it's becoming much easier for those
groups to get bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger in a way
they never would in in the real world if
you will so that's what i'm fascinated
with that's the area that i tend to
focus on the most um i mentioned earlier
the mob in the mind i think it's a part
of that as well um but it's just
starting to think of what is the
psychology of when people come together
in this really destructive way
but they say that they want
a productive outcome but you can tell by
their behavior
that they're never going to get that
outcome so that's kind of um
it's a little bit abstract but that's
that's how i see collective sabotage
playing out
yeah and i see i see what you're saying
is that
online especially
when we do this thing that like you're
either with us or against us you either
have all the answers or none of them
you're good or you're bad black white
all these things we we put ourselves in
a place that doesn't actually hear all
different perspectives and we get
farther and farther in in an echo
chamber and we become so divisive and so
separated and less communal as i think
would do so much better for our society
that's not saying we have to be like
dystopian like of course right but just
trying to understand where we can where
we're coming from and if we could become
more as a collective just willing to
hear each other out and willing to not
quickly blame someone or shame them or
name them this or that if they disagree
with you on this or that then we're more
likely to just understand each other
where we're coming from you don't even
have to agree
right but just understand i get why you
got there i get why you think that and
how you got there like that's so
that's so beautiful it reminds me of a
topic that
i ended up talking about online i did
like a single post i was feeling very
convicted like i really wanted people to
know
this is where i stand but in a very like
calm like
simple way was i did a post just
basically
sharing about basic biological facts of
baby in the womb and sharing that babies
have inherent value
just the biological facts of babies in
the womb at different time frames and i
was pregnant with kovacs at the time and
at the end i said the
babies in the womb have inherent value
and the difference between us and them
is time
and that's what i said
nothing else
but that blew up i mean i knew it would
happen right it's such a controversial
topic
and
it's very it's obviously i knew that
that would happen to a level but it's so
interesting how quickly something as
simple as that can
draw so much anger
and so much good bad wrong right you're
this
if we disagree on a specific topic right
that's so layered right
oh my goodness
even you know what as you were um
explain the post that you wrote i was
thinking oh that's so interesting as in
this is something that i would really
engage with regardless of where i quote
unquote stand just the fact that someone
is offering me this perspective and you
know that the only difference is time i
would find that just generally quite
interesting and then you know what would
happen i would see it and then i would
just move on with my life i would just
move on with my life but it's almost as
if that
thought doesn't occur to a lot of people
that if i see something and i like it i
can engage with it and then i like it
and then i get to move on if i see
something and i don't like it i get to
see it okay this is not for me and i get
to move on
we
think again that collective behavior
that collective anti-social behavior we
think that if i see this
and i feel uncomfortable and i filter it
through my own subjective experience my
own values my belief system and i don't
like it i feel discomfort in my body
then it's ellen's fault then she is a
bad person she has done something wrong
she has to delete this for my comfort
and the comfort of all of the thousands
of people that will see this
yeah and it's it's not normal
and i think i think it's also comes from
a place of feeling like a justice place
like this is we need to get the true
like what they believe to be the truth
or what they believe to be progressive
and helpful and so it comes from a place
of feeling justified
in the name of justice right
dehumanizing in the name of justice
isn't that wonderful
yes and i'm like hey if i was in person
with you i would love this conversation
like let's just talk about it and go
back and forth and anyone who knows me
on a personal level knows
knows that i love conversations with
different people different perspectives
um but in person it's just difficult
online is just such a crazy place i
think about young people and how hard it
must be for their developing brains yes
yes you know what that's a piece that
i'm really curious about actually and i
was i started thinking about this um
a few months ago
that it's
wonderful that i am having these
conversations with adults whether they
agree with me or disagree with me
agreement is not the goal disagreement
is not the goal conversation is the goal
but then i was thinking there are so
many young people that are growing up in
this environment and thinking this is
just normal behavior and thinking that
censoring themselves maybe they won't
even come to a day of thinking i think
i'm censoring myself because it's just
the default it's just normal that you
don't say what you actually think you
agree with whatever the majority says
you can't be curious or you can only be
curious in this context but all but not
in this one
it's making me realize that it's
actually young people that really need
this conversation the most so i do think
that in the next year or so
that will be my aim to just actually go
into schools and universities and
continue these conversations because i
think they shouldn't be
number one isolated to the digital space
even though it's becoming the space in
which we occupied the most which is a
little bit scary um but i think it also
needs to happen with young people so
they can learn how to relate to one
another even when
especially when they disagree
um
yes i mean it should actually be like a
core unit class i feel right
yeah yeah do you oh this makes me think
of your um
self-censorship event that you recently
had of like the work that you're doing
to help people can you talk a little bit
about that and can people still access
that if they're looking to like stop
self-censoring and just become more in
pa in their power to say how they really
feel
ah absolutely so
i
did it for the first time a couple of
months ago and it's how to stop
self-censoring in the age of cancer
culture
and it was
wonderful and the purpose of this event
which i will be running again in january
2022 or maybe if you're listening to
this in the future it should be
available by then um just as a
standalone course on my website but
the purpose of this was to give people
the how
and what i mean by that is through these
conversations and the work that i do and
just exploring what self-censorship is
what cancer culture is
what dehumanizing looks like
etc we can get stuck in the y we can get
stuck in sort of unraveling and then in
the theory and then in you know
intellectualizing it but for a lot of
people they just want to know how do i
actually integrate this into the real
world what does a practical approach to
undoing self-censorship actually look
like
you know if something happens in my
workplace and i feel compelled to say
something
what action do i take then you know what
level of risk should i be willing to
take so these are questions that i just
post to people but i also offer some
suggestions as a consultant of course um
because i think now we just need the
hell i think people
are terrified so much so that they don't
even know where to begin
and a lot of people end up getting stuck
in the y which i do think is important
because you need the information you
need the language to make sense of what
you're feeling what's happening in the
world but more than ever i think we just
need sustainable practical ways to
actually move out of this on a on an
individual and personal level um and
that's the work that i do with
individuals and groups so i'll be doing
this again in january 2022. oh perfect
so can people purchase it like already
uh done or is it just the live purchase
so at the moment the next one is going
to be live because there's something
just about doing it live because i like
to do it in a very interactive way where
people can ask any questions they have
but
by the spring 2022 it should be a
standalone course as well so you can
take yourself through it but i'm trying
to find a way of doing that in a way
where
it just doesn't become another course
that you buy but you actually can't
integrate the learning so i'm taking a
bit of time with that to see what people
actually need instead of just putting
something out there for the sake of it
but it it will be there and in the
meantime in a way people can always
engage with with my work i always try to
make it as practical as possible
without you needing to pay for anything
i i think should be accessible yeah oh
yeah you share so much amazing stuff on
your instagram everybody needs to go
follow you i will be talking about you
in an intro before this episode so
they'll be able to hear and learn a bit
more about you and i think when you talk
about self-censorship it's for people to
realize it's not just for people who are
on social media like this happens like
in your real life there's a lot of
people who are
who are afraid or have anxiety to
discuss with other people in their lives
their real thoughts about something if
they think the person they're talking
with disagrees with them
right and just really being able to just
say hey this is really where i'm coming
from without being afraid
of being judged or labeled and just
being able to hear each other's
perspectives without having the anxiety
go through the roof right yes oh i love
that i love that and you know what i
think will be useful
for even both of us or anyone listening
is to just give
make the distinction between
self-censoring and having a social
filter this is really important okay yes
so
right i'll start with the social filter
and just by me laying this out i think
it will offer
just clarity and i think it can also
give you a bit of relief
what i mean by that and what it looks
like is a social filter is something
that we have anyway intrinsically right
when you're with a certain group of
people
you're
you just approach the way you converse
differently there are things that you
know are not appropriate to say in
certain situations because you use your
self-awareness to really gauge the
context of the situation is this going
to be useful is this not going to be
useful and a really light-hearted
example that i can think of you know is
let's say you meet up with your aunt and
she's wearing you know kind of an ugly
jumper right but it's your aunt you
don't you don't tell her that it's not
useful in it's not useful information to
her what do you do you keep that to
yourself you keep that to yourself
because it's inappropriate it's not
going to be useful it will probably
tarnish the relationship or just make
things awkward and it's just generally
not nice right
in that moment are you censoring
yourself or are you using a useful
social filter
you're probably using a useful social
filter right especially if it's not
coming from a fear-based place but the
difference with self-censorship it's
always fear-based you think that you're
going to be punished you think that
you're going to be ostracized you think
you're going to be abandoned or rejected
or the term that we all know and love
cancelled um
so it's a very it's visceral and it's
physical and it's emotional and it's
mental and it doesn't feel as if you're
making a an informed decision from a
grounded place
like the jumper example that i've just
given you so a social filter is very
useful it's something that we all have
anyway
another very quick example that i can
use is that i love to swear but if i'm
around kids or if i'm around my mum it's
just i i won't do it i won't do it
because to me it's inappropriate and
it's not useful it's not going to add
anything it doesn't give me that same
zing of excitement as if you know it's
just different that's my social filter
that's not me censoring myself um and
also the process of undoing
self-censorship doesn't mean that you
just say whatever you want to say and
there aren't any consequences there are
always consequences for your speech and
i think that is a good thing right that
is a good thing we can get into a deep
discussion of who decides what's good or
bad etc etc but i think there are just
general sort of um
social agreements that we all have that
we can say yeah that that that's a good
thing
but i think it's about aiming for
mindful expression even when you're
uncomfortable even when things are a
little bit difficult because
self-censorship is always from a
fear-based place so i would say to kind
of practice
looking at am i centering myself here or
am i just being tactful and using my
social filter
yeah i think that that's a really
important distinction to make yeah
and it also reminds me of like
intellectual diversity
that you're talking about like there's a
difference between the social like hey i
don't need to talk about my you know say
my aunt's sweater isn't right is it nice
but like intellectual diversity within a
topic that's layered and deep and really
meaningful like to say how you really
feel and there's something you said
where you said
i want to repeat what you said in a post
that you did which i thought was amazing
you said true diversity and inclusion
doesn't and shouldn't stop at skin color
gender or sexuality it has to include
intellectual and viewpoint diversity
otherwise it's simply a performance
and i loved that so how do you respond
to somebody who says like well some
ideas are dangerous
and
like we need to draw the line somewhere
right like some ideas can be really
harmful so how would you respond to that
type of
right
question about what you've said
all right and that's a common one
actually not one that i
get all the time but it just depends on
what i'm talking about
but i see it being a question that's
sort of thrown out to anyone that um
advocates for the open exchange of ideas
so my answer to that would
be and i'm sure i've
written about this but
of course there are a lot of ideas that
are really not great ideas there are
some very extreme ideas there are
ideas
that i think can
influence dangerous behavior
but whether or not they are out there or
they are repressed
they exist right is it not better to
hear all of the ideas and hearing does
not mean agreement i think that part is
really important and i like to emphasize
that part because i think it disarms
people because of the binary thinking
people will will often assume that
by saying let's hear ideas it means
let's take on all of these ideas and
let's action them no but it means let's
just bring these ideas out of the
shadows so we can decide as a society or
as individuals or as a couple within
whatever conversational context
so we can decide what is useful and what
is not useful because whether you like
it or not those ideas exist and you can
shield yourself from them all you like
but it doesn't mean they will go
anywhere
actually they do go somewhere they
usually go into the shadows where they
get even more disturbing where they get
even more sinister so i think we need to
be able to cultivate our ability to hold
discomfort to be able to hear things
that we don't like to be able to hear
things that we disagree with but to be
able to work with that and say actually
i don't agree with that because and to
be able to work together as a society so
we can get good ideas because if we're
shutting everything down
that probably means that we're shutting
down a lot of good ideas because they
don't seem like something that we
immediately understand so hopefully that
makes sense but i think either way they
exist and i think it's much better to
shine a light on them than to shun them
into darkness i fully agree because when
these really truly dangerous ideas get
brought to light it's very clear to
people
and it makes it harder for them to
thrive
yeah i think um but then i also see how
quickly
the woke if you will right
will jump down and label something as
dangerous because they don't like what
that person said but that doesn't mean
it actually was dangerous and that's why
critical thinking comes into play so
like anyone listening to this that maybe
heard things that they're like i don't
agree with this or i can't believe that
ellen said this or
whatever like go and listen to this
other another opinion and then really
gauge what makes the most logical sense
to you not to what you're told to think
like critically think
you know
yeah i love that i love that because
it's a reminder for anyone listening to
be honest not just to us but if you
listen to anyone else having similar
conversations
that it's not about agreeing and it's
not about looking
searching for disagreement so you can
say aha see i knew
it's about just taking in the
information and as i always say just
filtering it through your own
self-awareness and then coming to an
informed opinion and just
watching at whether you're actually
responding to something or whether
you're just waiting for an opportunity
to react
right and people at the moment we're
being set up to just wait for the moment
where we can react and sort of get this
righteous reward which doesn't really
last for long um but i think it's much
more sustainable to just sit with the
idea of potential discomfort and then
make an informed decision about how
you're going to proceed with the
information you've just received yes on
a personal level not even necessarily
having to like say look you you're wrong
because of this exactly
like you said i actually really
appreciate how in a lot of your posts
you say hey and if you don't like what i
have to say here you feel free to move
on you do not have to
engage and make it a thing i love that
i love the the way you just said that
you just made me sound really
light-hearted and like hey you can
usually have much further than that i'm
like you can you can piss off if you
don't like it yeah the way that i
the way that i'm receiving it is you're
like hey feel free and you're like i
love that no that's the i'm very very
compassionate i'm a very compassionate
and soft person but i'm also very firm
um
so and i love that that can be felt
through my words
yeah but again i think you do have to
set boundaries it makes such a big
difference even if it's just writing a
line
um
or just saying what you won't tolerate
you will have some people that will drop
off but i promise you if you are someone
that shares something online or
even if you don't have a quote-unquote
big following i mean just try it you get
to set the terms and i think we forget
that so much
which means it invites people that
because they don't have boundaries they
expect you to not have boundaries but
you say actually no there is a way that
we operate here and if you don't like it
you don't have to engage but i invite
you to stay even if you don't like it
but you just have to be respectful um so
i yeah i think that's a good approach
respect is absolutely everything because
people are going to receive what you
have to say so much better if you just
say hey i disagree because of this in a
in a respectful way for sure or just
moving on and sharing what you're
passionate about and being the one to
put it out into the world
we talked about so many good things i
i am a little nervous just to be fully
transparent of how it's going to be
received by sharing
my experience because like you said of
the way the whole identity politics the
way of that even though i feel confident
in my stance and i feel confident in
what i've looked into and what my
friends experiences and what
you know me just sharing my experience
alone is just you know it's a delicate
situation
but i'm excited at the same time because
i find this topic so fascinating
i find
listening to the the layers and under
trying to understand the nuance and the
heart of like how we can really move
forward as a collective and yes in a
positive way
so i guess my last question to you would
be like what do you think could happen
if we stopped self-censoring as a
collective and stopped self-sabotaging
and became
really in tune on a large level
obviously it doesn't mean everybody but
on a large level if we really tapped
into that to like really listening to
each other and just trying to understand
where we came where we're coming from
and like
let go of these obsession with identity
politics and
things like that like where where could
we go forward where would it take us
with like victor mentality
that's such a beautiful question uh even
as
you were talking i can just feel sort of
like my shoulders just relaxing at the
idea of us just not being absolute
vicious animals to each other
and here's the thing if i'm being
totally honest and i'm a very hopeful
person i think some things are just hard
wired in us
as primal beings in terms of how we sort
of just flock to tribalism and we want
to find our groups and we want to you
know i i think some things are sort of
hardwired within us so i don't think
they'll ever be um
not necessarily a utopia but maybe even
something before that i don't think
we'll ever get to that level of just
cohesion and understanding etc but i do
think that if we manage which i think we
can to just pull ourselves away from
these extremes and just find our way
back to the middle i think it will just
be much easier to coexist i think it
will just be much easier to actually
understand each other i think we can
come to a point where we recognize our
differences but we're not threatened by
our differences i think we could come to
a point of
being curious about what makes us
similar because we are so
similar
you know um
we seem to think that everything that is
happening right now for example we're
the first to ever experience this
you know
i'm sure so many times over the course
of let's say 100 200 300 years the
people then thought that they would be
the last civilized civilization to exist
because of the intensity of what was
happening
and i think we're just experiencing our
part of that where things just become so
shocking and so unavoidable but we can
get through it we can get through it i
don't think it's going to be perfect but
i think even just the fact that you and
i ellen can sit here today after
everything that happened in 2020 you as
a white woman um although i shouldn't
assume your
race according to the ideology this is
where you shout at me
don't be a bigot
the fact that we can even have this
conversation
to me is a big sign it's a big sign that
something is shifting and i think that's
what it's going to look like it's just
conversation after conversation and then
the amount of people that listen to this
they carry the conversation into their
own lives even if they just get the
courage to share it on their story and
they never normally wouldn't that's
that's playing a part in us unraveling
this so i think it's already happening i
think it's already happening i do too i
do too especially a lot of the
places that i'm you know
listening to and seeing that people are
being more aware i think are just open
to different ideas and i think i think
maybe
before social media like a decade ago it
didn't feel
so divisive
but maybe
right yeah to me it didn't at least
maybe that's not everybody's experience
but then social media created such a
huge divide and if we and if we could
and i think we are a little bit now
seeing
how easily it has become to become
divided that maybe we can start to just
come a little bit more together i think
the way you worded that was so beautiful
being
coexisting together
right completely
yeah and i'd love to know um from you
and are you
would you say you're hopeful
when you sort of see everything that is
happening and
just even from your own very personal
experiences of something like 2020 um
would you say you're hopeful or
something else
yeah i definitely feel hopeful i i feel
like i'm a generally a positive person
and i like to see the good
and it just feels good inside to be
speaking on these things that feel
good to me and as long as i'm doing
what feels right in my own body and mind
that helps me to be in a good head space
and then just seeing the world in a
positive way and i i do think it is i
think things are continually getting
better but then when i talk to some
people they're like no it's not and i'm
like i know
i could i could see both sides but i'm
generally hopeful i i am yes what about
you i'm with you i'm with you i'm right
there with you that's why i have this
huge smile because anyway i'm always
smiling and laughing the world could be
burning and i'll just be laughing
but i'm hopeful i'm hopeful and i'm ah i
cannot wait
to share this conversation and to just
create more conversation um and i'm
doing a lot of research right now
actually just understanding the
psychology of some of the things that
we've spoken about so maybe we can come
together in a year or something yes and
do a part two so i can just share some
of these findings with you oh that would
be so fun or we could even tackle a
different topic because honestly yes
like i mean we could do this same type
of topic too and see where we're at a
year from now but also yeah i feel like
you generally get a sense of like when
you disagree with someone on a certain
thing that like oh that would be such a
good conversation i just feel it because
it would be positive respectful friendly
like yeah we should figure out what we
disagree about and then we should have a
conversation that would be fun so much
fun i'm in i'm in okay we'll plan it
we'll we'll do some digging and figure
out where are we
for sure oh this was such a good
conversation i'm so thankful for you
coming on and i just appreciate
everything you're sharing it's so
helpful i think for so many people to
listen and just soak in and just realize
that your mind is so powerful and your
addiction story is incredible i know we
didn't get too much into it you
explained in the beginning some of it
but i encourage anyone to go listen to
any of
her podcasts that she's been interviewed
on or even on her own podcasts and
it's an incredible story so you're very
inspiring and i just appreciate you
coming on
thank you so much thank you i
i mean i i had sifted through the
conversations that you've had before and
everything you share and i knew that
this would be such a rich exchange but i
i feel so recharged and light and it's
just flown by it doesn't feel like
however long it's been at all
um and i just admire your courage as
well and you said earlier that you feel
a little bit nervous
and i i
still sometimes feel a little bit
nervous depending on what i'm talking
about and i think those nerves are
useful because they show you that you're
doing something that you care about they
remind you of your integrity as well
because it means that even though you're
feeling those sort of uncomfortable
feelings you're still moving through it
because you know this is the right thing
to do so i can i can only admire that
thank you oh wow that's such a good way
to put it it's so true it means that
you're really doing something like when
you have those nerves you're about to do
something big or something you really
want to do even if it's small it could
be something small but you really need
to do it in your heart yes that's such a
good way to say it
yeah
well thank you africa
okay lastly though i'm trying to think
you know how we're going um
when you're talking about writing a post
and you're thinking okay what are people
gonna say
what's the thing that people are gonna
say and how can i shift this and word
this differently or how do i how am i
just aware of how people respond because
i think you and i our brain kind of
works similar in that way because i see
the way that you post and like yes i
would so say it that way type of thing
yes but
the one thing or maybe not the one but
maybe the main
a criticism i do see happening from this
conversation towards me
would be ellen you're tokening africa
how are you not
how are you not going to have on someone
else with
the the stance that you disagree with
about like wokeness blm all the all
these types of things and i hate
honestly i think the word tokening is
disgusting to me and mass majority of
the time that is not the case
and the assumptions i know i'm jumping
back into our conversation that was just
about to end
but it reminds me i'm like well just a
couple more minutes because it reminds
me of um
certain things that have that like even
my personal experience of that being
labeled you're tokening someone when
it's like so far from the truth like a
pr like an example would be like i
posted a picture once on thanksgiving of
my friends
and i was like i'm so thankful for my
friends and we were all together not all
of us it was some of my friends some
people were still missing and in the
comments it was like
some people obviously not everybody
there's so many loving kind people out
there most people are loving and kind
it's just the
harsh
responses can seem louder in your brain
yes
but um
something would say you have
why are all your friends white you have
too many white friends and to when i
reply
when i replied well
actually two of the girls in this
picture are mexican and then they say oh
you're tokening them i'm like what no
you're the one who pointed out
the color and so i was just responding
to you and that that's a place that
we're in right now that i think is so
unhealthy this obsession and zubie
talked about that too that he's like i
get all the time you'll be like why do
you have so many white friends he's like
i live in britain where most people are
white like what do you want me to do
uh and and you know what actually i do i
do think this is an important piece of
all of this because
i don't imagine people would for example
send me a message and tell me that i am
uh you know tokening myself it would be
likely to be the other way around but
what what that implies as well
the reason why this is actually racist
in
in itself is that it implies that i
am incapable of of making a decision for
myself that i want to engage in this
conversation
that it plays into that whole um
power dynamic obsession that somehow you
have this power dynamic that you get to
just pick any
person of color quote unquote
and you can just use them for your own
very personal agenda not that i have
something very important and nuance to
say
and that this is the work that i do when
i'm looking at something that is
happening culturally and we align on a
lot of our values so we're having a
conversation that is important it can't
just be
that objective and true and simple it
has to be some sinister
thing that
confirms that i'm in a powerless
position and you're weaponizing your
supposed power
it's disgusting it's so disgusting it's
actually it's assuming it's assuming
that
i'm not having you on because i actually
think what you have to say is
fascinating and intellectual and just
emotional and very like emotional to me
and impactful to me it's assuming that
i'm having you on because of the color
of your skin and that you are powerless
in your ability to detect if somebody is
tokening you or not it's it's a dig at
you it's actually more a dig at you
it's actually it's actually it's
actually just disgusting to me
ah so i am glad that you brought that up
i am glad that you brought that up
because i don't think um
to be honest i've never had two people
that are sort of
just in terms of identity are pinned
against each other i've never really had
that very short and simple exchange
happen publicly and i think it will
snap a lot of people maybe out of their
own judgments that maybe they didn't
realize were lacking yes oh oh i can't
wait for a part two with you oh my gosh
we have to do it we're putting a pin in
it and maybe one day you can come to
hawaii oh i would love to oh my gosh i'm
going to be um
in the u.s next year
probably in the first four months of the
year so i will come and visit you oh my
gosh that will make
that'll make my year i'll be so excited
if you come okay we're gonna plan it
stay tuned for part two everybody in
person interview
wow this is amazing thank you africa oh
thank you
i can't wait to share this all right bye
everyone thanks for joining
[Music]
you